The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, today we are
moving on with renewal
processes, and we're going to
finish up talking a little
more about residual life, and
we're going to generalize it
to time averages for arbitrary
renewal processes.
And then finally we're going
into the topic of stopping
trials, stopping times, optional
stopping times--
people call them different
things--
and Wald's equality.
This is, for some reason or
other, normally a very tricky
thing to understand.
I think finally after many
years I understand it.
And I hope that I can make it
easy for you to understand it,
so some of the confusions that
often come in won't come in.
And then we're going to end up
talking about stopping when
you're ahead, which is a
gambling strategy which says
if you're playing a fair game
you play until you're $1.00
ahead, and then you stop.
And you show that with
probability 1 you will
eventually become $1.00 ahead,
so you have a way to beat the
bank, or beat the casino.
But of course casinos don't give
you even odds, but you
have a way to win any time
you get even odds.
We'll find that there's
something wrong with that, but
it is an interesting topic
which illustrates Wald's
equality in an interesting
way.
So let's start out by reviewing
a little bit.
We first talked last time
about convergence with
probability 1, and we weren't
talking about the strong law
then, we were just talking about
a sequence of random
variables and what it means
for them to converge with
probability 1.
And the theorem is that if you
have a sequence of random
variables, z sub n, they
converge to some number alpha.
This is slightly different than
the theorem we stated
last time, but it's trivially
the same.
In other words, it's the
probability of the set of
sample points.
A sample point, now, is
something which runs from time
0 to time infinity.
It's something that covers the
whole process, covers anything
else you might want to
talk about also.
It's what you do when you go
from a real situation to a
model, and mathematically when
you go to a model you put in
everything you're going to be
interested in at the beginning.
So, it converges to some alpha
probability 1 if the set of
sequences for which the
statement holds has
probability 1, and this
statement is that the sample
paths converge to alpha.
The set of sample paths has
converged to alpha as
probability 1.
So, it's a statement not like
most of the statements in
probability where you start
out talking about finite
length, talking about
probabilities, and
expectation, and so forth.
And then you go to the limit
with these things you're used
to talking about, which are
easier to deal with.
Here it's a statement
about sample paths
over the whole sequence.
You break them into
two categories.
Implicitly we have shown that
when you break them into two
categories those two categories
in fact have
probabilities.
They are events, and one of
them has probability 1.
For renewal processes, if we
have a renewal process we can
use this theorem to talk about
the sample averages.
In other words, in a renewal
process we have a sequence of
IID random variables, x1,
x2, x3, and so forth.
We have the sample sums, the sum
of the time 1, the sum of
the time 2, sum of the
time 3, and so forth.
And the strong law of large
numbers, which comes pretty
much directly out of this
convergence of probability 1
theorem, says that the
probability is the set of
sample points for which the
limit of the sample average,
namely sn of omega over n.
You take the sample average
over all lengths for one
sample point.
That goes to a limit, that's
this convergence with
probability 1, the probability
that you get convergence is
equal to 1, which is what with
probability 1 means.
Then we use the theorem
on the top.
Let's reset a little bit.
This theorem on the top is more
than just a theorem about
convergence with
probability 1.
It's the reason why convergence
with probability 1
is so useful.
It says if you have some
function f of x, that function
is continuous at this
point alpha.
You have this limit here, then
the probability of the set of
omega for which the function
applied to each of these
sample points as equal
to alpha is also one.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It should
be f of alpha.
Yes, absolutely.
Sorry about that.
This is f of alpha
right there.
So that probability
is equal to 1.
I'm finally getting my bearings
back on this.
So if I use this theorem here,
where I use f of x as equal to
1 over x, then what it says for
a renewal process, which
has inter-renewals x1, x2, and
so forth, with a inter-renewal
process the expected
inter-renewal time, which
might be infinite in general,
but it has to
be bigger than 0.
It has to be bigger than 0
because renewals in 0 time are
not possible by definition.
And you've done a problem in the
homework, or you will do a
problem in the homework, whether
you've done it or not,
I don't know, but when you do
it, it will in fact show that
the expected value of x has
to be greater than 0.
We're also assuming that it's
less than infinity.
So, at that point we can use
this theorem which says that
when you look at, not sn of
omega over n, but the inverse
of that, n over sn of omega, the
limit of that is going to
be equal to f of x-bar which
is 1 over x-bar.
So we have this limit here
which is equal to 1 with
probability 1.
This is almost the strong law
for renewal processes, and the
reason why it's not takes a
couple of pages in the text.
What I'm going to try to argue
here is that the couple of
pages, while you need to do
mathematically, you can see
why when you do it you
can see what answer
you're going to get.
And the argument is
the following.
We talked about this last
time a little bit.
If you take an arbitrary time t
then you look at n of t for
that value of t, that's the
number of arrivals you've had
in this renewal process
up until time t.
And then you compare this point
down here, which is the
time of the last arrival before
time t, and this point
here, which is the time of the
next arrival after time t, and
you look at the slopes
here, this slope here
is n of t over t.
That's the thing we're
interested in.
That expression there is the
time average of the number of
renewals within time t, and what
we're interested in is
what this becomes as
t goes to infinity.
That's squeezed between this
slope here, which is n of t
over s sub n of t.
This is s sub n of t.
And this point here is n of t,
and this lower band here,
which is n of t divided by
s sub n of t plus 1.
Now, all this argument is
devoted to proving two things,
which are almost obvious and
therefore I'm just going to
wave my hands about it.
What this says is when t gets
very, very large, n of t
becomes very, very large also.
When n of t becomes very, very
large, the difference between
this slope and this slope
doesn't make a hill of beans
worth of difference, and
therefore those two, that
upper band and that lower
band become the same.
So with the argument as t gets
large, n of t gets large, and
these two slopes become the
same, you suddenly have the
statement that if you have
a renewal process and the
inter-renewal time is less than
infinity, it has to be
greater than 0.
Then on a sample path basis the
sample paths, the number
of arrivals per unit time,
converges to 1 over x-bar.
That's what this previous
picture was saying to you.
It was saying that n over t over
t, which is the number of
arrivals per unit time t, as t
becomes very, very large on a
sample path basis that becomes
equal to 1 over x-bar.
So, it says that the rate of
renewals over the infinite
time horizon is 1 over x-bar
with probability 1.
And what probability 1 statement
again is saying that
the set of sample paths for
which this is true has
probability 1.
This also implies the weak law
for renewals, which says that
the limit as t approaches
infinity of the probability
that n of t over t minus 1 over
x-bar is greater than
epsilon goes to 0.
This, surprisingly enough,
is a statement that
you hardly ever see.
You see a bunch of other renewal
theorems, which this
theorem up here is probably
the most important.
There's something called an
elementary renewal theorem,
which is sort of a trivial
statement but
kind of hard to prove.
And there's something called
Blackwell's theorem, which
talks about a local period of
time after time gets very,
very large.
It's talking about the number
of renewals in some tiny
interval and it's proving things
about stationarity over
that local time interval.
And we'll talk about that later,
but this is sort of a
nice result, and that's
what it is.
Let's review residual
life a little bit.
The residual life of a renewal
process at time t, the
residual life is the time you
have to wait until the next
renewal, until the
next arrival.
So residual life means,
how long does it take?
If you think of these renewals
as something that comes along
and kills everybody, then this
residual life is the amount of
life that people still
have left.
So, if you look at what that
is for a particular sample
path, I have a particular
sample path drawn here,
completely arbitrary.
When I look at the first arrival
time here, s1 of
omega, and I look at all of
the time before that, the
amount of time you have to
wait until this arrival.
Remember this is one
sample point.
We're not thinking in terms of
an observer who comes in and
doesn't know what's going
to happen in the future.
We're looking at one
sample point.
We know the whole
And what we're doing we know
this, we know this, we know
this, and all we're doing here
saying for each time t along
this infinite path we're just
plotting how long it is until
the next arrival.
And that's just a line with
slope minus 1 until the next
arrival occurs.
After the next arrival and you
start waiting for the arrival
after that, after that
when you wait for the
arrival after that.
So on a sample path basis, the
residual life is just this
sequence of isosceles
triangles here.
So we looked at that, we said,
if we look at the time from n
equals 1 up until the number
of arrivals at time t, the
number of triangles we
have is n of t omega.
The size of the area of each
triangle is xi squared over 2.
The size of each triangle is xi
squared over 2, and when we
get all done we want to take the
average of it so we divide
each of these by t.
This quantity here is less than
or equal to the integral
of y of t over t, and that's
less than or equal to the same
sum where if we look at a
particular time of t this sum
here is summing everything
up to this point.
This sum here is summing
everything up to this point.
And as t goes to infinity, this
one little triangle in
here, even though this is the
biggest triangle there, it
still doesn't make
any difference.
As t goes to infinity,
that washes out.
You have to show that, of
course, but that's what we
showed last time.
When we go to the limit we find
that this time average
residual life is equal to the
expected value of x squared
over twice the main effect.
Now, this can't be infinite.
You can have a finite expected
in a renewal time and you can
still have an infinite
second moment.
If you look at the example we
talked about last time where
the inter-renewal time at two
possible values, either
epsilon or 1 over epsilon, in
other words, it was either
enormous or it was very, very
small, what we found out there
was that some of these
inter-renewal intervals, a
very small fraction of them, but
a very small fraction of
the inter-renewal intervals
were enormously large.
And because they were enormously
large, the time
average residual life turned
out to be enormous also.
You think of what happens
as epsilon
get smaller and smaller.
You can see intuitively why it
makes sense that when you have
humongously long inter-renewal
times, and you have this x
squared that occurs, because of
this triangle here, I think
is possible to see why this
quantity here can't become
infinite if you had this
situation of a very long
tailed distributions for
the inter-renewal time.
You have enormously long
residual waits then, and you
have them with high probability,
because if you
come into this process at some
arbitrary time you're somewhat
more likely to wind up in one of
these large intervals than
one of the small intervals, and
that's what causes all the
trouble here.
There are similar
examples here.
You can look at the age of a
process, z of t is defined as
the interval between t and
the previous arrival.
So, if we look at sum time t,
the age at that point is the
amount of time back to the
previous arrival that goes up
like a triangle, drops as soon
as we get the next arrival.
It's exactly the same.
It's just the same thing
looking at it backwards
instead of forwards, so the
answer is the same also.
If you look at something called
duration, the question
here is at a particular
time t.
If we take the difference
between the next arrival and
the previous arrival, that's
called the duration of time t.
How big is that?
Well, obviously this is the same
problem as that, and the
residual life and in fact,
that's exactly the sum of the
residual life and the age.
So, it's not surprising that
the time average--
oh my.
There should be a
2 down there.
So it's exactly the same
situation as we had before
when we were talking about
residual life.
Now we'd like to generalize
this, and I hope the
generalization is almost
obvious at this point.
These three quantities here are
all examples of assigning
rewards to renewal processes.
And the reward at any time t,
when I'm trying to do this, is
restricted to be a function of
the inter-renewal period
containing t.
In other words, when you try to
define what the reward is
at a given time t, it's a
function only of what's going
on in a renewal period
containing t.
Now, in its simplest
form, I want to go
make this even simpler.
In its simplest form r of t is
restricted to be a function of
the age of time t and the
duration of time t.
In other words, you try to say
what's the reward in a given
time t, and it's the
same as these three
examples we looked at.
It's some function of how far
back do you have to go to the
previous arrival, and how far
forward do you have to go on
until the next arrival.
You can make this a function if
you want to of any of the
three quantities residual
life, age, and duration.
It seems to be intuitively a
little simpler to talk about
age and duration as opposed
to the other quantities.
So the time average for sample
path of r of t is found by
analogy to residual life.
That's the way I'm going
to do it here in class.
The notes do a little
more careful job
than just by analogy.
But you start with the n-th
inter-renewal interval and you
say, what is the aggregate
reward I get in the n-th
inter-renewal interval?
It's a random variable,
obviously.
And what it is is the integral
from the previous arrival up
to the next arrival of
r of t and omega dt.
This is very strange, because
when we looked at this before
we talked about n of t and we
talked about s sub n of t plus
1 and s sub n of t, and suddenly
n of t plus 1 has
turned into n, and n of t has
turned into n minus 1.
What has happened?
Well, this gives you a clue.
And it's partly how we
define the intervals.
Interval 1 goes from 0 to s1 and
z of t equals t, interval
n z of t is t minus
s sub n minus 1.
Let me go back and show you the
original figure here and I
think it will make it clear.
Now, the first arrival comes
at this time here.
The first interval we're talking
about goes from 0 to
time s1 of omega.
What we're interested in, in
this first interval going from
0 to s1 of omega, is this
interarrival time, which is
the first interarrival time.
This first interval is connected
to x1 and it goes
from s sub 0, which is
just at 0 up to s1.
The second arrival time
goes from s1 up to s2.
When we look at n of t, n of
t is a sum t here in this
interval here, and this is s.
Am I going to get totally
confused writing
this or aren't I?
I think I might get totally
confused, so I'm not going to
try to write it.
Because when I try to write
it I'm trying to make the
comparison between n of t and
n of t plus 1, which are the
things up here.
But the quantities here with the
renewal periods are, this
is the first inter-renewal
period, this is the second
inter-renewal period.
The second inter-renewal period
goes from s sub 2 back
to s sub 1.
The n-th goes from s sub n
back to s sub n minus 1.
So that's just the way it is
when you count this way.
If you count it the other way
you would get even more
confused because then in the
interval x sub n the
inter-renewal time would
be x sub n plus 1 and
that would be awful.
So, this is the way
we have to do it.
Let's look at what happens
with the expected
inter-renewal time, then,
as a time average.
And you can think of this as
a being for a sample time.
When you have an expression
which is valid for a sample
time, it's also valid for a
random variable, because it
maps every sample point
into some value.
So, I'll just call it here r sub
n, which is the amount of
reward that you pick up in the
n-th inter-renewal period, so
it's the integral from the n
minus first arrival up to the
n-th arrival, and we're
integrating over r of t over
this whole interval.
So r of t is a function of the
age and of the duration.
The age is t minus s sub n minus
1, and the duration is
just x of n.
Now that's a little weird also
because before we were talking
about the duration as being
statistically very, very
different from the inter-renewal
period.
But it wasn't.
If you look on a sample path
basis, this duration of the
n-th inter-renewal period is
exactly equal to x sub n of
omega, which is, for that
particular sample path, it's
the value of that inter-renewal
interval.
So when we integrate this
quantity now, we want to
integrate it over dt.
What do we get?
Well, we've gotten rid of this
t here, we just have the n-th
duration here.
The only t appears over here,
and this is r of a difference
between t and s sub n minus 1.
So, we want to do a change of
variables, we want to let z be
t minus s sub n minus 1,
and then we integrate z
from 0 to x sub n.
And now just imagine that you
put omegas in all of these
things to let you see that
you're actually dealing with
one sample function, and when
you leave the omegas out
you're just dealing with the
random variables that arise
because of doing that.
So when we do this integration,
what we get is
the integral of r of z with this
fixed x sub n integrated
against dz.
This is a function only of the
random variable x sub n.
Strange.
That's the expected
value of r sub n.
This unfortunately can't be
reduced any further, this is
just what it is.
You have to find out what is
the integral of r of zx
integrated over z, and then we
have to take the expected
value over x.
If the expectation exists, you
can write this in a simple
way, because this quantity
here integrated
is just r sub n.
And then you take the expected
value of r sub n, and you
divide by x-bar down here.
This quantity here is just the
expected value of the integral
of r of zx dz.
And that integral there
is just the expected
value of r sub n.
So, if you look over the entire
sample path from 0 to
infinity, what you get then is
that the time average reward
is just equal to the expected
value of r sub n
divided by x squared.
Oops.
Lost the example.
Suppose we want to find the
k-th moment of the age.
Simple thing to try to find.
I want to do that because
it's simple.
If you're looking at the k-th
moment of the age looked at as
a time average, what it is is
the reward at time t, it's the
age at time t to
the k-th power.
We want to take the age to the
k-th power at time t, and then
integrate over rt and divide
by the final value
and go to the limit.
So the expected value of
this k-th moment over 1
inter-renewal period is this
integral here, z to the k dz
times dF sub x of x.
The only place x comes in this
integral is in the final point
of the integration where we
are integrating up to the
point x, at which the duration
ends, and then we're taking
the expected value of this.
So, we integrate this, the
integral of the z to the k
from 0 to x is just x to the
k plus 1 divided by k.
So when you take that integral
and you look at
this, what is this?
It's the 1 over k times the
expected value of the random
variable, x to the k
plus first power.
That's just this taking the
expected value of it, which is
you take the expected value
by integrating times
the s sub x of x.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
divide by k plus 1?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
I'm sorry.
My evil twin brother is speaking
this morning, and
this should be a
k plus 1 here.
This should be a k plus 1, and
this should be a k plus 1.
And if you look at the example
of the first moment, which is
the first thing we looked at
today, namely finding the
expected value of the age, what
we find out is that it's
expected value of x squared
divided by 2 times x-bar.
So with k equal to 1 we get
the expected value of x
squared over 2 times x-bar.
It's even worse because I left
a 2 out when we were talking
about the expected
value of age.
And to make things even worse,
when I did this I went back to
check whether it was the right
answer, and of course the two
mistakes cancelled
each other out.
So, sorry about that.
The thing I really wanted to
talk about today is stopping
trials for stochastic processes,
because that's a
topic which has always caused
confusion in this class.
If you look at any of the
textbooks on stochastic
processes, it causes even
more confusion.
People talk about it, and then
they talk about it again, and
they say what we said before
wasn't right, and then they
talk about it again, they say
what we said before that
wasn't right, and it goes
on and on and on.
And you never know
what's going on.
Very often instead of looking
at an entire stochastic
process over the infinite
interval, you'd like to look
at a finite interval.
You'd like to look at the
interval going from 0 up to
some time t.
But in almost a majority of
those cases, the time t that
you want to look at is not
some fixed time but some
random time which depends on
something which is happening.
And when you want to look at
what's going on here, it's
always tricky to visualize this
because what you have is
t becomes a random variable.
That random variable is a
function of the sample values
that you have up until time t.
But that seems like a circular
argument, t a random variable
and it depends on t.
Things are not supposed to
depend on themselves, because
when they depend on themselves
you have trouble understanding
what's going on.
So, we will sort that out.
In sorting it out we're
only going to look at
discrete-time processes.
So, we'll only look at sequences
of random variables.
We will not assume that these
random variables are IID for
this argument here, because we
want to look at a much wider
range of things.
So we have some arbitrary
sequence of random variables,
and the idea is you want to
sit there looking at this
evolution of the sequence of
random variables, and in fact,
you want to sit there looking
at the sample
path of this evolution.
You want to look at x1, and you
want to look at x2, and
you want to look at
x3, and so forth.
And at each point along the line
in terms of what you've
seen already, you want to decide
whether you're going to
stop or whether you're going
to continue at that point.
And if at that point you develop
a rule for what you're
going to do with each point you
call that a stopping rule,
so that you have a rule that
tells you when you want to
stop looking at these things.
Let me give you some idea of
the generality of this.
Often when we look at queuing
systems we are going to have
an arrival process where
arrivals keep coming in,
things get serviced one after
the other, and one of the very
interesting things is whether
the system ever empties out or
whether the queue just keeps
building up forever.
Well, an interesting stopping
rule then is when the queue
empties out.
We will see that an even more
interesting stopping rule is
starting with some arbitrary
first arrival at time 0.
Let's look for the time until
another arrival occurs which
starts another busy period.
These stopping times, then, are
going to be critical in
analyzing things like
queuing systems.
They're also going to become
critical in trying to analyze
these renewal systems that we're
already talking about.
They will become critical to
trying to take a time average
view about renewal processes
instead of a, not a time
average, but an ensemble average
viewpoint looking at
particular times t as opposed
to taking a time average.
So we're going to look
at these things in
many different ways.
In order to do that, since
you're looking at a sample
function, you're observing
it on each
arrival of this process.
At each observation of a sample
value of a random
variable, you decide whether
you want to stop or not.
So a sensible way to deal with
this is to look over all time,
define a random variable J,
which describes when this
sequence is to be stopped.
So for each sample value x1 of
omega, x2 of omega, x3 of
omega, and so forth, if your
rule is to stop the first time
you see a sample value which
is equal to 0, then J is a
integer random variable whose
value is the first n at which
is x of n is equal to 0 and
many other examples.
So we try a 1 then, x1
of omega is observed.
A decision is made based
on x1 of omega
whether or not to stop.
If we stop, J of
omega equals 1.
If we don't stop, J of omega is
bigger than 1, but we don't
know what it is yet.
At trial two, if we haven't
stopped yet, you observe x2 of
omega, the second random
variable, second sample value,
you make a decision again based
on x1 of omega and x2 of
omega whether or not to stop.
If you stop, J of omega
is equal to 2.
So you can visualize doing this
on each trial, you don't
have to worry about whether
you've already stopped, you
just have a rule that says, I
want to stop at this point if
I haven't stopped before.
So the stopping event at time
n is that you stop either if
your rule tells you to stop
or you stop before.
And if you stop before then
you're obviously stopped.
At each trial n if stopping has
not yet occurred x of n is
observed and the decision based
on x1 to xn is made.
If you stop, then J omega
is equal to n.
So for each sample path J of n
is the time or the trial at
which you stop.
So, we're going to define a
stopping trial, or stopping
time, J for a sequence
of random variables.
You're going to define this to
be a positive integer-valued
random variable that has to be
positive, because if you're
going to stop before you observe
anything that's not a
very interesting thing.
So you always observe at least
one thing, then you decide
whether you want to stop or
you proceed, so forth.
So it's a positive
integer-valued random
variable, you always stop at an
integer trial, and for each
n greater than or equal to 1 the
indicator random variable
the indicator of the event J
equals n is a function of what
you have observed up
until that point.
This part is a really
critical part of it.
The decision to stop at a time n
has to be a function only of
what you have already
observed.
You're not allowed as an
observer to peek ahead a
little bit and then decide on
the basis of what you see in
the future whether you want to
stop at this time or not.
One example in the notes is that
you're playing poker with
somebody, and you make a bet
and the other person wins.
You make the bet on the basis
of what you've seen in your
cards so far, you don't make
your bet on the basis of your
observation of what the other
player has, and the other
player will get very angry if
you try to base your decision
later on what the person you're
playing with has.
So you can't do that
sort of thing.
You can't peek ahead when
you're doing this.
You could design random
variables where, in fact, you
can look ahead, but the times
where you use what people call
stopping trials are situations
in which you stop based on
what has already happened.
You can generalize this, and we
will generalize it later,
where you can stop on the
basis of other random
variables, which also evolve in
time, but you stop on the
basis of what has already
happened up until time n.
We're going to visualize
conducting successive trials
until sum n in which the event
J equals n occurs.
Further trials then cease.
It is simpler conceptually
to visualize stopping the
observation of trials after
the stopping trial, but
continuing to conduct trials.
In other words, if we start
talking about a stopping
process and we say we stop on
the n-th trial, but we're
forbidden to even talk
about the n plus
first random variable.
Now the n plus first random
variable occurs on some sample
paths but doesn't occur
on other sample paths.
I don't know how to deal with
that, and neither do you.
And what that means is the way
we're going to visualize these
processes is physically they
continue forever, but we just
stop observing them at
a certain point.
So, this stopping rule is the
time at which we stop
observing as opposed to the
time at which the random
variable ceases existing, if we
define the random variable,
it has a value for all sample
values, and sample values
involve all of these paths.
So you sort of have to
define it that way.
One thing you would like to do
is in many of these situations
you wind up never stopping.
And the trouble is, when you're
investigating stopping
rules, stopping trials, you
usually don't know ahead of
time whether you're ever
going to stop or not.
And because of that if you
don't know whether you're
going to stop or not,
you can't call
it a stopping trial.
So, what one normally does is
to say that J is a possibly
defective random variable.
And if it's possibly defective
you mean that all sample
points are mapped into either
finite J or perhaps J equals
infinity, which means
that you never stop.
But you still have the same
condition that we have here,
that you stop on the basis
of x1, x of n.
And you also have the condition,
which isn't quite
clear here, but it's clear
from the fact that J is a
random variable, that the events
J equals 1, J equals 2,
J equals 3, are all disjoint.
So you can't stop twice, you
have to just stop once.
And once you stop you
can't start again,
Now does everybody understand
what is stopping trial or a
stopping rule is
at this point?
If you don't understand it I
think the trouble is you won't
realize you don't understand it
until you start seeing some
of these examples where strange
things are going on.
I guess we have to just
go ahead and see
what happens then.
So the examples, which
I'm not going to
develop in any detail.
A gambler goes to a casino and
he gambles until he's broke.
So, he goes in with a finite
amount of capital.
He has some particular system
that he's playing by.
If he's lucky he gets to play
for a long, long time, he gets
a lot of amusement as he loses
his money, and if he's unlucky
he loses very quickly.
If you look at the odds in
casinos and you apply the
strong law of large numbers,
you realize that with
probability 1 you get wiped
out eventually.
Because the odds are
not in your favor.
Casinos wouldn't be built if the
odds were in your favor.
Another example, just
flip a coin until 10
successive heads appear.
10 heads in a row.
That's a rather unlikely
event.
You're going to be able to
figure out very easily from
this theory what's the expected
amount of time until
10 successive heads appear.
It's a very easy problem.
A more important problem, this
test and hypothesis with
repeated trials.
So, you have the hypothesis
that a certain kind of
treatment will make patients
well, and you want to know
whether to use this treatment.
So you test it on mice, or
people, or what have you.
If you think it's pretty
safe, you start
testing it on people.
And how many tests
do you make?
Well, you originally think that
as a scientist you should
plan an experiment ahead of
time, and you should say, I'm
going to do 1,000 tests.
But if you're doing experiments
on people and you
find out that the first 10
patients die, you're going to
stop the experiment
at that point.
And if you find out that the
first 100 patients all live,
well, you might continue
the experiment.
But you're going to publish
the results at that point
because you're going to try to
get the FDA to approve this
drug, or this operation,
or this what have you.
So if you view this stopping
trial as the time at which
you're going to try to publish
something, then, again, if you
have any sense, you are going
to perform experiments, look
at the experiments as you go,
and decide what you're going
to do as a function of what
you've already seen.
I mean, that's the way that all
intelligent people operate.
So if science says that's not
a good way to operate,
something's wrong
with science.
But fortunately science
doesn't say that.
Science allows you to do this.
AUDIENCE: So not every J is
potentially defective?
You can come up with
examples of
where it would be defective.
But not every one is necessarily
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
If a random variable is
defective it means there's
some probability that J is
going to be infinite, but
there's also presumably some
probability that J is equal to
1, a probability J is equal
to 2, and so forth.
So we have a distribution
function for J, which instead
of going up to 1 and stopping
goes up to some smaller value
and stops, and then it doesn't
go any further.
AUDIENCE: Not every
[INAUDIBLE].
Some of these are definitely
going to [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So this testing hypotheses is
really what triggered Abraham
Wald to start trying to
understand these situations,
because he found out relatively
quickly that it
wasn't trivial to understand
them, and all sorts of crazy
things were happening.
So he spent a lot of his time
studying what happened in
these cases.
He called it sequential
analysis.
You might have heard the word.
And sequential analysis is
exactly the same idea.
It's looking at analyzing
experiments as you go in time,
and either stopping or doing
something else or changing the
experiment or what have you,
depending on what happens.
Another thing is observe
successive renewals in a
renewal process until
s sub n is greater
than or equal to 100.
Now, this particular thing is
one of the things that we're
going to use in studying renewal
processes, it's why
we're studying this
topic right now.
Well, we might study it now
anyway, because we're going to
use it in lots of other places,
but it's also why you
have to be very careful about
talking about stopping time as
opposed to stopping trials.
Because if you stop an
experiment at the arrival in a
renewal process at which that
renewal occurs after time 100,
you don't know when you're
going to stop.
It might be a very long time
after 100 before that first
arrival after time 100 occurs,
it might be a very short time.
So it's not a stopping time that
you're defining, it's a
stopping trial.
You are defining a rule which
tells you at which trial
you're going to stop as opposed
to a rule that tells
you in which time you're going
to stop, and we'll see this as
we go on in this.
Suppose the random variables in
this process we're looking
at have a finite number of
possible sample values.
Then any possibly defective
stopping trial, and a stopping
trial is a set of rules for
when you're going to stop
observing things, any stopping
trial can be represented as a
rooted tree.
If you don't know what a rooted
tree is, a rooted tree
is what I've drawn here.
So, there's no confusion here.
A rooted tree is something that
starts on the left hand
side and it grows for a while.
It's like an ordinary tree.
It has a root, and it has
branches that go up.
But any possibly defective
stopping trial can be
represented as a rooted tree
where the trial at which each
sample path stops
is represented
by a terminal node.
So the example here I want
to use is the same
example as in the text.
I was trying to get another
example, which will be more
interesting.
The trouble is with these trees
they get very big very
quickly, and therefore this is
not really a practical way of
analyzing these problems.
I think it's a nice conceptual
way of analyzing.
So, the experiment is x is a
binary random variable, and
stopping occurs when the pattern
1, 0 first occurs.
You can certainly look at any
other pattern you want to, any
much longer pattern.
But what I want to do here is to
illustrate what the tree is
that corresponds to this
stopping rule.
So if the first random variable
has a value 1 and
then the second one has a value
0, you observe 1, 0, and
at that point the experiment
is over.
You've seen the pattern
1, 0, and you stop.
So there's a big circle there.
If you observe 1 followed by a
1 followed by 0, again you
stop 1, 1, 1, followed by a
0 you stop, and so forth.
If you observe a 0 and then you
observe a 1 and then you
observe a 0, that's the first
time at which you've seen the
pattern 1, 0 so you
stop there.
0, 1, 1, 0, you stop there,
and so forth.
So you get this kind of
ladder structure.
The point that I want to make
is not that this particular
structure is very interesting.
It's that whatever kind of rule
you decide to use for
stopping, you can express
it in this way.
You can express the points at
which you stop by big circles
and the points at which you
don't stop as intermediate
nodes where you keep on going.
I think in some sense this takes
the picture which you
have of sample values, of sample
functions with the rule
that each sample value, which
is often the easiest way to
express stopping rules, but in
terms of random variables it
doesn't always give you
the right story.
This gives you a story in terms
of all possible choices
of the random variables.
The first toss has to be
either a 1 or a 0.
The second toss has to be a 1
or a 0, but if it's a 0 you
stop and don't go any further.
If it's a 1 you continue
further.
So you keep continuing
along here, you can
continue forever here.
If you want to analyze
this, it has a
rather peculiar analysis.
How long does it take until
the first 1, 0 occurs?
Well, if you start out with a 1
this experiment lasts until
the first 0 appears.
Because if the 0 doesn't appear
right away another 1
appears, so you keep
going along this
path until a 0 appears.
If you see a 0 first and then
you see a 1, you're back in
the same situation again.
You proceed until a 0 occurs.
What this is really saying is
the time until you stop here
consists of an arbitrary number,
possibly 0 of 0's,
followed by an arbitrary number,
possibly 0 of 1's,
followed by a single 0.
So the only patterns you can
have here which would lead to
these terminal nodes are some
number of 0's followed by some
number of 1's, followed
by a final 0.
But the example is not
important, so that just tells
you what it means.
With all of this we finally
have Wald's equality.
And Wald's equality, it looks
like a strange thing.
I spent so much time talking
about stopping rules because
all the complexity lies
in the stopping rules.
Wald's equality itself is a very
simple thing after you
understand that.
What Wald's equality says is,
let x sub n be a sequence of
IID random variables, each
would mean x-bar.
This is the kind of
thing we've been
talking about a lot.
If J is a stopping trial for x
sub n, n greater than or equal
to 1, in other words, if it
satisfies that definition
where it never peeks ahead, and
if the expected value of J
is less than infinity, then the
sum s sub J equals x1, x2,
up to x sub J, the amount that
the gambler has accumulated
before the gambler stops.
The sum of the stopping trial
satisfied expected value of
the gain as equal to the
expected value of x times the
expected number of
times you play.
It sort of says that even when
you use these stopping rules
to decide when to
stop, there's no
way to beat the house.
If you're playing a fair game,
your expected gain is equal to
the expected gain for trial
times the expected number of
times you play.
And there's no way you
can get around that.
Note that this is more
than a [? poof ?]
and less than a proof.
I'll explain why it's more
than a [? poof ?]
and less than a proof
as we go.
s sub J, the random variable s
sub J, it's equal to x sub 1
times the indicator function
of j greater
than or equal to 1.
In other words, well, the
indicator function J greater
than or equal to 1 is
just universally 1.
x sub 2 times the indicator
function of J greater than or
equal to 2.
In other words, s sub J includes
x sub 2 if the
experiment proceeds long enough
that you take the
second trial.
In other words, this quantity
here, is 1 minus the
probability that you stop at
the end of the first trial.
You continue here, each x
sub n is included if the
experiment has not been
stopped before time n.
So the experiments continue
under the event that the
stopping time was greater than
or equal to the J. So the
expected value of s of J is
equal to the expected value of
this sum here, of x sub n times
the indicator function
of J greater than or equal to
n, which is equal to the sum
over n of the expected value
of x sub n times this
indicator function.
By this time I hope that most
of you are at least a little
bit sensitive to interchanging
expectations and sums.
And the notes and the problem
sets deal with that.
That's the part of the proof
that I don't want to talk
about here, because it isn't
really very interesting.
It's just one of these typical
tedious analysis things.
Most of the time
this is valid.
We will see an example where
it isn't, so you'll see
what's going on.
The essence of the proof,
however, the interesting part
of the proof is to show that xn
and this indicator function
are independent random
variables.
So you can think of that as a
separate limit, that the n-th
trial and the indicator function
of J greater than or
equal to n are independent
of each other.
This seems a little bit weird,
and it seems a little bit
weird because this includes
the event that
J is equal to n.
And the event that J is equal
to n is something that's
decided on the basis of the
previous arrivals, or the
previous what have you.
It's highly influenced
by x sub n.
So, x sub n is not independent
of the indicator
function of J equals n.
So this is strange.
But we'll see how
this works out.
Now, if we want to show that
x sub n and this indicator
function are independent, the
thing that you do is note that
the indicator function of J
greater than or equal to n,
this is the set of events in
which J is greater than or
equal to n.
What's the complement
of that event?
The complement of the event J
greater than or equal to n is
the event J less than n.
So this indicator function
is 1 minus
this indicator function.
J less than n is the complement
of the event J
greater than or equal to n.
When you perform the experiment
either this
happens, in which case this is
1, or this happens, in which
case this is 1, and if
this is 1, this is 0.
If this is 1, this is 0.
Also, the indicator function
and J less than n is a
function of x1, x2, up
to x sub n minus 1.
Let me spell that out a little
more because it looks a little
strange the way it is.
i of J less than n is equal to
i if the indicator random
variable for J equals 1.
Union with the indicator
random variable
for J equals 2.
Union indicator function
for J equals n minus 1.
These are all disjoint events.
You can't stop at two
different times.
So if you stop before time n you
either stop at time 1, or
you stop at time 2, or you
stop at time n minus 1.
This event is independent.
Well not independent, it
depends on x sub 1.
This event depends
on x1 and x2.
This event depends on x1
up to x sub n minus 1.
OK, so this is what I mean when
I say that the event J
less than n is determined by
x1 up to x of n minus 1,
because each of these sub events
is determined by a sub
event up there.
Since we're looking at the
situation now where the x is
our IID and this event is a
function of x1 x of n minus 1,
it just depends on those
random variables.
These random variables are
independent of x sub n so i of
J less than n is independent of
x sub n and thus x sub n is
independent of J greater
than or equal to n.
Now, as I said, this is very
surprising, and it's very
surprising because this event,
J greater than or equal to n,
typically depends very
heavily on x sub n.
It depends on J equals n
plus 1, and so forth.
So it's a little paradoxical
and the resolution of the
paradox is that given that J is
greater than or equal to n,
in other words, given that you
haven't stopped before time n,
the time at which you stop
is very dependent on the
observations that you make.
But whether you stopped before
time n or whether you haven't
stopped before time n is
independent of x sub n.
So it really is this
conditioning here that makes
this a confusing issue.
But whether or not J greater
than n occurs depends only on
x1 up to x sub n minus 1.
And with that it's easy enough
to finish the proof, it's just
writing a few equations.
The expected value of s sub J is
equal to the sum over n and
the expected value of x sub n
times the indicator function
of J greater than
or equal to n.
We've just shown that these
are independent.
This random variable is
independent of this random
variable, that's independent of
the event J greater than or
equal to n, so it's independent
of the random variable.
The indicator function is J
greater than or equal to n, so
we can write this way.
Now, when we have this
expression each of the x sub
n's are IID, so all of these are
the same quantity x-bar.
So since they're all the same
quantity x-bar we can just
take it outside of
the summation.
So we have x-bar times the sum
of the expected value of i of
J greater than or equal to n.
Now, the expected value of this
indicator function, this
indicator function is 1 when J
is greater than or equal to 1,
and it's 0 otherwise.
So the expected value of this
is just a probability that J
is greater than or equal to n.
So, this is equal to the
expected value of x times the
sum of the probabilities
that J is greater
than or equal to n.
This is really adding the
elements of the complimentary
distribution function for J, and
that gives us the expected
value of J. If finite or not
finite gives us this anyway.
So, this really is a proof
except for that one step.
Except for this interchange of
expectation and summation here
which is, well, we will get an
idea of what that has to do
with anything.
So let's look at an example.
Stop when you're ahead.
And stop when you're ahead
is a strategy for
gambling with coins.
You toss a coin with
probability of
heads equal to p.
And we want to look at all the
different cases for p, whether
p is fair or biased in your
favor or biased in the other
person's favor.
And the rule is that you
stop whenever you're
winnings reach one.
So you keep on dumbly gambling,
and gambling, and
gambling, until finally you get
to the point where you're
one ahead and when you're one
ahead you sigh a sigh of
relief and say, now my wife
won't be angry at me, or my
husband won't divorce me, or
something of that sort.
And you walk away swearing
never to gamble again.
Except, when you look at
this you say, aha!
If the game is fair, I am sure
to win, and after I win I
might as well play again,
because I'm sure to win again,
and I'm sure to win again, and
I'm sure to win again, and so
forth, which is all
very strange.
And we'll see why that
is in a little bit.
But first let's look at
the case where p is
greater than 1/2.
In other words, you have a
loaded coin and you've talked
somebody else, some poor sucker,
into playing with you,
and you've decided you're going
to stop the first time
you're ahead.
And because p is greater than
1/2, the expected value of
your gain each time you play
the game is greater than 0.
You're applying IID random
variables so that eventually
your winnings, if you kept
on playing forever,
would become humongous.
So at some point you have to be
1 ahead in this process of
getting to the point where
you're arbitrarily large
amounts ahead.
So with probability 1, you will
eventually become ahead.
We would like to know since we
know that you're going to be
ahead at some point, how
long has it going to
take you to get ahead?
We know that j has to be a
random variable in this case,
because we know you have to win
with probability 1 s sub J
equals 1 with probability 1.
Namely, your winnings up to the
time J. At the time J your
winnings are 1.
So s sub J is equal to 1, the
expected value of s sub J is
equal to 1, and Wald says that
the expected value of J, the
expected time you have to play,
is just 1 over x-bar.
Isn't that neat?
Which says it's 1
over 2p minus 1.
The expected value of x is p
plus minus 1 times 1 minus p
and if you look at that it's 2p
minus 1, which is positive
when p is bigger than 1/2.
After all the abstraction of
Wald's equality it's nice to
look at this and solve it in a
different way to see if we get
the same answer.
So we'll do that.
If J is equal to 1, that means
that on the first flip of the
coin you've got heads, you
became 1 up and you stopped.
So the experiment was over
at time 1 if the
first toss was a head.
So if the first toss was a tail,
on the other hand, what
has to happen in order
for you to win?
Well, you're sitting there at
minus 1 and you're going to
stop when you get to plus 1.
Every time you move up one or
down one, which means if
you're ever going to get from
minus 1 up to plus 1, you've
got to go through 0 in
order to get there.
So let's look at the expected
time that it takes to get to 0
for the first time, and then
we'll look at the expected
time that it takes to get from
0 to 1 for the first time.
Well, the expected time that it
takes to get from minus 1
to 0 is exactly the same as
the expected time that it
takes to get from 0 to 1.
So, the equation that you then
have is the expected value of
J is going to be 1.
This is the first step you have
to take anyway, and with
probability 1 minus p you went
to minus 1, and if you went to
minus 1 you still have J-bar
left to go to get to 0 again,
and another J-bar to get to 1,
so J-bar is equal to 1 plus
failing the first time it
takes 2J bar to get
back up to plus 1.
If you analyze this equation,
J-bar is equal to 1 plus
2J-bar minus 2Jp-bar, you work
that out and it's just 1 over
2p minus 1.
So fortunately we get the same
answer as we got with the
Wald's equality.
Let's go one again.
Let's look at what happens if
you go to the casino and you
play a game where you
win $1 or lose $1.
But the probability in casinos
is somehow always tilted to be
a little less.
If you play for red or black in
roulette, what happens is
that red or black are equally
likely, but there's the 0 and
double 0 where the house
always wins.
So your probability of winning
is always just a little less
than 1/2, so that's the
situation we have here.
It's still possible
to win and stop.
Like if you win on the
first toss, then
you're going to stop.
So J equals 1 with
probability p.
J equals 3 if you lose,
and then you win,
and then you win.
So J equals 3 with probability
p squared times 1 minus b.
And there are lots of other
situations you can look at J
equals 5 and see when you win
then, and you can count all
these things up.
Let's try to find a simple
way of counting them up.
Let's let theta be the
probability that J is less
than infinity.
In other words, theta is the
probability that you're ever
going to stop.
Sometimes in this game you won't
ever stop because you're
going to lose for while, and
as soon as you lose a fair
amount you're very unlikely to
ever recover because you're
drifting South all the time.
Since you're drifting South,
theta is going to
be less than 1.
So how do we analyze this?
Same way as before, given that
J is greater than 1, in other
words, given that you lose on
the first trial, the event J
less than infinity requires that
at some time you go from
minus 1 back up to 1.
In other words, there's some
time m at which s sub m minus
s sub 1 is equal to 1.
s sub m is the time at which
you first get from minus 1
back up to 0, and then there's
some time that it takes to get
from 0 up to 1, and
there's some
probability that ever happened.
The probability that you ever
reach 0 is equal to theta, the
probability you ever get from 0
up to plus 1 is theta again.
So theta is equal to p, which
is the probability that you
win right away, plus probability
you lose on the
first toss, and you ever get
from minus 1 to 0 and you ever
get from 0 to 1.
So theta equals p plus 1 minus
p times theta squared.
There are two solutions
to this.
One is that theta it is p over
1 minus p and the other is
theta equals 1, which we
know is impossible.
And thus J is defective,
and Wald's equation is
inapplicable.
But the solution that we have,
which is useful to know, is
that your probability of ever
winning is p over 1 minus p.
Nice to know.
That's what happens when
you go to a casino.
Finally, let's consider the
interesting case which is p
equals 1/2.
The limit as p approaches 1/2
from below, probability that J
less than infinity goes from
p over 1 minus p goes to 1.
In other words, in a fair game,
and this is not obvious,
there's probability 1 that you
will eventually get to the
point where s sub
n is equal to 1.
You can sort of see this if you
view this in terms of the
central limit theorem.
And we looked pretty hard at the
central limit theorem in
the case of these binary
experiments.
As n gets bigger and bigger, the
standard deviation of this
grid grows as the square
root of n.
Now the standard deviation is
growing as the square root of
n and over a period of n
you're wobbling around.
You can see that it doesn't
make any sense to have the
standard deviation growing with
the square root of n if
you don't at some point go from
the positive half down to
the negative half.
If you always stay in the
positive half after a certain
point, then that much time later
you're always going to
stay in the same half again, and
that doesn't work in terms
of the square root of n.
So you can convince yourself on
the basis of a very tedious
argument what this very simple
argument shows you.
And as soon as we start studying
Markov chains with
uncountably infinite number of
states, we're going to analyze
this case again.
In other words, this is a very
interesting situation because
something very interesting
happens here and we're going
to analyze it at least
three different ways.
So if you don't believe
this way, you will
believe the other way.
And what happens as p approaches
1/2 from above you
know the expected value of
J approaches infinity.
So what's going to happen at p
equals 1/2 as the expected
time for you to win goes to
infinity, the probability of
your winning goes to 1, and
Wald's equality does not hold
because the expected value of x
is equal to 0, and you look
at 0 times infinity and it
doesn't tell you anything.
The expected value of s sub J s
sub n at every value of n is
0, but s sub n when the
experiment ends is equal to 1.
So there's something very funny
going on here and if you
think in practical terms though,
it takes an infinite
time to make your $1.00 and more
important, it requires
access to an infinite capital.
We will see that if you limit
your capital, if you limit how
far South you can go, then in
fact you don't win with
probability 1, because you
can go there also.
Next time we will apply this
to renewal processes.